every dough has a limit even pitbulls
have a limit it just requires a human
who takes the time you know it's not
about 5 minutes 10 minutes 15 minutes
yes as long as it takes you focus on
what you want to create I'm taking the
tail away from between his legs yeah
because that creates fear I want him to
be not surrender the more you fight the
more he relieves that independence there
you go
see and then I answer okay this is what
I want yeah so you have to also learn
when to stop there you go that's better
stay and then after he went into a very
aggressive stay he went to a panic state
you know so what I came natural to me is
to put him on this side so he can relax
because when they're on the side this
way there is a sense of relaxation sense
of trust sense of vulnerability where
they just totally surrender and give up
this is just it's panic
people that have come in before to
health Jake really wasn't helping him in
fact it made it worse
and we made it worse because we were
following their beliefs and techniques
now when you when they ask you to do
this behavior that he went through the
same thing yes and did you ever
accomplish the whole relaxation well he
always put up a fight that's what we
look that's what I'm looking for you
know obviously he has somebody has done
this and not accomplished the whole
you know I'm not using as sort of inside
of me you know I'm using more calm side
of me am i taking a person I'm not
getting frustrated you know come on you
have to do this in five seconds even
though he's on the side right now I'm
not trying to dominate I'm just trying
to relax okay okay this is pretty good
he's staying in that position for a long
period of time so he so they you know we
we stay there when he was stands we stay
there when he was aggressive and we stay
there when he was panic and then we
waited until he relaxed that creates the
trust just to see Jake the end result
being him laying down is is amazing